wo sind Jasmin Gündogan und die 8
Millionen Euro die sie geklaut hat in so
einer Kiste die Polizei die Jagt die
Bremerin mit europäischem Haftbefehl
denn die Spur führt ins Ausland und zu
kriminellen arabischen Clans
und wir kommen zu Jasmin Gündogan 28
Jahre alt Deutsch Türkin aus Bremen
1,60 m groß und 8 Millionen Euro schwer
so viel Geld hat sie von einem
Geldtransportunternehmen erbeutet bei
diesem Unternehmen da hatte sie vorher
gearbeitet und bei ihrem Beutezug bei
diesen Diebstahl da soll Jasmin Helfer
gehabt haben eine Spur die führt ins
Clan Milieu die Polizei die sucht jetzt
in diesem Moment nach Jasmin Gündogan
sie ist sogar mit einem europäischen
Haftbefehl zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben
und sein Computerexperten den ist es
gelungen basierend auf den offiziellen
Fahndungsfotos von Jasmin sie als
Computer 3D Avatar in unser Studio zu
bringen also helfen Sie der Polizei
schauen Sie genau hin und schauen sie
auch jetzt auf unsere exklusiven
Recherchen von meinen Kollegen Sascha
Baumann Jörg völkerling Lilly von der
Osten und China Chaka
die 28 Jahre alte jasmin hat in Bremen
gearbeitet
für das Verpacken der Kundengelder unter
anderem das hat sie auch an dem Pfingst
Freitag gemacht hat
Container hat diesen Container in einen
angemieteten Mercedes Vito gepackt und
dann aber mit dem Geld auch und davon
hat sich krankgemeldet ja und jetzt ist
sie auf der Flucht nichts Millionen
uhrzäune Stacheldraht und überall
Videokameras hier an der Ausfahrt des
Bremer wehrtransportunternehmens Lumis
verliert sich am 21 mai gegen 21:15 Uhr
die Spur von Jasmin Gündogan eine
Überwachungskamera zeichnet auf wie die
28-Jährige mit einem Mercedes Vito die
Einfahrt verlässt an Bord 8 Millionen
Euro
wer ist die Frau die kaltblütig 8
Millionen Euro klaute Bildreporter Jörg
völkeling geht auf Spurensuche will mit
yasemins Eltern sprechen doch keiner
macht die Tür auf Jasmins Vater ruft vom
Balkon aus zu dass sie in die Situation
völlig fertig macht und der 24 Stunden
am Tag von der Polizei überwacht werde
[Musik]
hier in Bremer Stadtteil
und ihre Schwester zuletzt in diesem
Block hinter mir ihre Familie willst du
den Vorwürfen gegen die 28-Jährige nicht
sagen angeblich hatten sie selbst seit
fast drei Monaten keinen Kontakt mehr zu
ihr
in yasemins Wohnblock hat die Nachricht
von Millionen Kuh die Runde gemacht
viele haben Angst vor der Kamera zu
sprechen
alles gut danke schön es gelingt uns mit
Freunden und Schulkameraden Kontakt
aufzunehmen für sie ist klar Yasemin hat
das Ding nicht alleine durchgezogen
ich war selbst schockiert als ich es
gelesen habe dass sie das gemacht haben
soll und da dachte ich mir schon so das
kann ich mir alleine von ihr nicht
vorstellen warum nicht weil sie so
unbedarf war nein weil sie auf deutsch
gesagt sehr hart ausgedrückt zu dumm ist
dafür was auch schon einige gesagt haben
sie ist halt zu naiv gewesen dafür also
nie im Leben wird sie das alleine
gemacht haben
wer steckt hinter dem millionendiebstahl
wir recherchieren im Bremer Hauptbahnhof
Viertel denn eine Spur führt in die
Shishabar Ocean 27 dort hatte Yasemin
seit 2014 gearbeitet auch privat soll
sie oft da gewesen sein sonst werden
Videoaufnahmen zugespielt zum ersten Mal
sehen wir Yasemin in der Shisha Bar die
junge Frau wird vertraut entspannt kam
sie hier in Kontakt mit ihren späteren
Komplizen laut Anwohnern wird die Shisha
Bar von einer kriminellen Großfamilie
kontrolliert entstand hier der
gemeinsame Plan für den Millionen Q oder
wurde Yasemin dazu gezwungen
unsere Spurensuche geht weiter mit
diesem in Berlin gemieteten Mercedes
Vito hatte Yasemin die Beute
abtransportiert zuvor waren am
Nachmittag des 21 mai die Kennzeichen in
einer Kleingartensiedlung in Bremen
gestohlen worden wir finden den Mann
dessen Nummernschild für den
millionenkuh benutzt wurde
okay
so wie sie aussieht ist sie bestimmt
nicht dabei den Wagen bei gegangen also
ich habe nur das Bild in der Zeitung
gesehen gehabt kann ich mir die
vorstellen da müssen mehrere
unterstützen
die Polizei hat inzwischen eine
Komplizin festgenommen nähere Angaben zu
dieser Frau werden jedoch mit dem
Verweis auf die laufenden Ermittlungen
zurückgehalten und Jasmin Gündogan die
Ermittler haben einen Verdacht
manche Länder liefern nicht aus Trotz
europäischen Haftbefehl das ist
natürlich eine Hürde
die Spur führt in die Türkei wir
erhalten Hinweise das Yasemin im
Großraum Antalya untergetaucht ist wir
schicken unseren Kollegen Celal Chaka
auf Recherche
Antalya ist einer der größten Städte der
Türkei über Yasemin Gündogan wurde in
den türkischen Medien berichtet dass sie
sich hier aufhalten könnte hier im Basar
würde sie ganz einfach unter das Volk
sich mischen können und Untertauchen
es kann sein dass Yasemin Gündogan in
die Türkei gekommen ist es kann auch
sein dass sie sogar nach Antalya
geflohen ist Natalia ist eine große
touristische Stadt Menschen aus aller
Welt kommen hierher gute sowie schlechte
z.B Mitglieder der russischen Mafia
leben hier wie unschuldige Menschen mit
ihren Familien woher ich das weiß solche
Sachen habe ich schon öfter erlebt ich
bin halt Journalist hier in Antalya
tätig die Kriminellen komme aus allen
Ländern auch aus Deutschland her und
lassen sich hier nieder
am Schwarzen Meer dort leben die
Großeltern der flüchtigen Millionen die
bin diese treffen wir nicht an dafür
einen Onkel von Yasemin vor versteckter
Kamera verleugnet er seine Enkelin ich
kenne sie nicht sie ist deutsche
Jasmin Gündogan bleibt verschwunden doch
wir fahren noch mittlerweile sind ihr
spezielle Zielfahnder auf der Spur ihre
Familie hofft dass sie noch am Leben ist
und nicht nur Handlangerin für den
Millionen Diebstahl war und anschließend
als Zeugin beseitigt wurde
und sie haben es gehört die Bremer
Polizei die bestätigt hier bei achtung
Fahndung zum ersten Mal dass sie im Fall
Jasmin günduan tatsächlich wegen
möglicher clancomplizen ermittelt und
dieser Spur der wollen wir natürlich
nachgehen mit unserem absoluten
planexperten unserem Chef Reporter Frank
Schneider der uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist
guten Abend Frank und sag uns einmal
welcher Clan kontrollierten in Bremen
die Nachtwelt und Unterwelt
in Bremen so mehr oder weniger die
vorherrschende macht im Bereich der
Großfamilien es handelt sich hier mehr
oder weniger um 30 Familien in einer
Struktur von ungefähr zweieinhalb
tausend Mitgliedern das zeigt schon wie
groß diese Gruppe ist und die Polizei
sagt eben natürlich nicht alle
Mitglieder dieser Großfamilie aber viele
sind doch beteiligt an Erpressung
Schutzgeld Drogen und Waffenhandel auch
das Rotlichtmilieu ist ein Bereich in
dem sich Mitglieder dieser Großfamilie
umtun und der Clan hat damals sogar eine
eigene rockergruppierung gegründet die
Mongols und wollte damit sogar die
Vorherrschaft im Rockermilieu hat sich
sogar mit den Hells Angels angelegt und
ist sehr martialisch und brutal
aufgetreten um sich Eindruck zu
verschaffen hinterher sind die Mongols
verboten worden aber die Gefahr des
mirikladens zeigt sich vielleicht auch
daran als ein Pate abgeschoben werden
sollte dieses Miri Clans hat die Polizei
die GSG9 die Spezialeinheit die normal
gegen Terroristen eingesetzt wird
geschickt weil sie Sorge hat ein
amerikanmitglieder könnten
möglicherweise versuchen diesen Paten zu
befreien ich stehe jetzt hier in Essen
denn Essen ist neben Bremen und Berlin
eine der Hochburgen lib jaclans und auch
dieser Kriminalität und wir sind hier im
Herzstück im Essener Polizeipräsidium wo
es um diese Bekämpfung von
Kleinkriminalität geht wir können das
einmal zeigen wir sind hier im
sogenannten Lagerraum hier sitzen an den
ganzen Stühlen Polizisten wenn es wieder
zu einer Razzia kommt und dazu kommt es
hier wirklich fast täglich wir sehen
hier oben an der Wand das können auch
einmal zeigen das hat die Polizei uns
erlaubt das ist von letzter Woche nur
sechs Tage her das war wieder eine
Razzia da steht erste Welle 18.08 das
wird hier in Wellen durchgeführt es gibt
Razzien immer wieder von mehreren
Objekten ich kann nur mal die letzten
200 Jahre Bilanz erzählen die ist
wirklich beeindruckend es handelt sich
hier um über 1000 Spielhallen Shisha
Bars und Gaststätten die durchsucht
worden über 700 Personen wurden
festgenommen es gab über 150 Haftbefehle
es gab sicher gestellte Waffen über 100
Stück es gab sicher gestellte Fahrzeuge
im Millionenwert diese Luxuskarossen ist
ja etwas was den Clans unglaublich
wichtig ist zu zeigen Macht zu
präsentieren ihren Wohlstand ihren
agaunerten Wohlstand und neben mir steht
hier der essen sei Präsident Frank
Richter er ist jemand der mehr oder
weniger Vorkämpfer ist im Bereich der
Kleinkriminalität fast drei Jahre kämpft
die Essener Behörde schon mit
Unterstützung ist
nordrhein-westfälischen Innenministers
Herbert Reul gegen die Clans Herr
Richter wir haben gerade die Bilanz
schon gehört die sehr beeindruckend
warum ist die Kleinkriminalität
überhaupt so gefährlich und warum muss
sie so bekämpft werden wie Sie das hier
tun es gibt
ist das muss immer sagen die kriminellen
Clans die wirklich kriminell sind die
Plünderung unserer Sozialsysteme
vornehmen das ist ein eine Ausnutzung
unseres Sozialstaates die uns allen
schadet und das sind Millionenbeträge
die dort unrechtmäßigerweise in diese
Taschen gehen ein zweiter Punkt ist es
viel Bevölkerung sehr sehr wichtig Plan
Mitglieder halten sich nicht an deutsche
Gesetze und deutsche Regeln die sagen es
gibt das Gesetz der Familie und man
versucht vor allen Dingen und größeren
Gruppen Menschen einzuschüchtern man
muss noch nicht mal etwas sagen man
besetzt die Gehsteige und vieles mehr
und wenn
ich doch nicht gut geht man auch brutal
im vor gegen andere
das auch gegen die Polizei das haben wir
am Anfang unserer Aktion sehr sehr stark
gemerkt dass das auch eine Frage von zur
Schaustellung von macht ist und nach dem
Motto diese Straße gehört uns dieser
straßenzucht dieser Stadtteil gehört uns
ähm das sorgt vor allen Dingen dafür
dass die Menschen ein
Unsicherheitsgefühl haben da haben wir
sehr stark und sehr Konsequenz
gegengearbeitet und der dritte Bereich
selbstverständlich die organisierte
Kriminalität alles was man sich
vorstellen kann sie hatten es erwähnt ob
das schon Waffen sind ob es im
Drogenhandel ist und vieles vieles mehr
das ist ungefähr vergleichbar mit
anderen Bereichen der organisierten
kamillität das ist schon ein Punkt der
uns natürlich auch sehr viel
längerfristig
beschäftigen wird wir haben es jetzt
gerade gehört in Bremen ist
möglicherweise eine Frau manipuliert
worden zu helfen was sagen sie aus ihrer
Erfahrung ist das normal für Clan werden
Menschen auch manipuliert und benutzt
also diese Erfahrung haben in den
letzten Jahren auch gemacht es gibt im
Grunde um drei Kategorien die erste
Kategorie ist das immer noch Menschen
sehr fasziniert sind von diesen Clan
selbst Fernsehserien zeigen das und auch
die Nähe suchen der zweite Punkt ist der
dort wo man wirklich Menschen unter
Druck setzt in Ämtern vor allen Dingen
dort Ihnen auch droht und dann
Informationen weitergibt und was wir
festgestellt haben auch im Bereich
der Neueinstellung auch bei der Polizei
dass man versucht sehr gezielt Menschen
aus dem clan-menü aus dem kriminellen
Clan Milieu sehr bewusst einzuschleusen
und dann irgendwann auch den profiter
rauszubekommen ja vielen Dank Herr
Richter man hat gehört es ist sehr sehr
beeindruckend welchen Kampf die Polizei
hier führt ich will noch eine Ermittler
zitieren der sagte kürzlich das einzige
was hilft gegen diese kriminellen Clans
das ist wirklich konsequente
Strafverfolgung Razzien gut gemeinte
Ratschläge nutzen da nichts und damit
jetzt zurück nach Berlin zu dir Max ins
Studio Frank vielen vielen Dank für
deine Einblicke dort aus Essen ja wir
haben es gehört Jasmin Gündogan also
weiter auf der Flucht aber Ziel fahren
da die sind ihr in diesem Moment auf der
Spur und deshalb bittet die Polizei um
ihre Hilfe und fragt ganz konkret wer
kann Angaben zum Mittätern und deren
Aufenthaltsort machen und wer hat
womöglich Hinweise auf das Verbleib des
Geldes zeugenhinweise nimmt die
Kriminalpolizei Bremen unter
04213620 entgegen